the user images the Chinese government
doesn't want you to see a medical center
in Wuhan the epicenter of the corona
virus outbreak under stress short on
supplies overwhelmed with patients the
video is from chuncho a lawyer who made
the risky choice to become a citizen
journalist and defy government efforts
to control information in front of me is
the virus and behind me is the legal and
administrative power of China as long as
I live in this city
oh I will continue to report I only
report what I see what I hear I'm not
even scared of death you think I'm
afraid of the Communist Party
no Chun is gone he disappeared last week
and has not responded to messages so far
authorities will only say he is quote
under control
Amnesty International say he's been
forcibly quarantined and he's not the
only one to pay the price for defying
state authority the blogger fang bin
took this video from a hospital in Wuhan
it seems to show body bags victims of
the virus then he received a menacing
knock on his door you would you go do
you deny email Chinese surrender to that
blue one in Central Park
haha fiying had been posting videos
daily proof that he was free those
uploads stopped on Monday and he's been
unreachable by phone fueling speculation
of his arrest when Li wen Liang a doctor
in Wuhan warned of the virus in December
authorities accused him and several
others of severely disturbing the social
order no he's dead one of the more than
1000 people in China to succumb to
coronavirus so far mourning and anger
have marked his passing online and off
in defiance of the state's threats
pressure is mounting on Chinese
authorities to come clean on what's
happening in Wuhan
and that includes wanting to know what's
happened to people like chuncho and fine
bin okay let's get the latest on the
situation in China now at EWS Matias
Billina joining us from Beijing good day
to you Matias um what information are
people in China not getting that they so
desperately want to hear well nobody in
China knows whether these numbers that
we see are real every information that
we get from Wuhan is that it might even
not be deliberate it might also be
deliberate that might also not but a lot
of patients have not been diagnosed yet
people are queuing up in hospitals in
order to be admitted to a hospital you
need to show symptoms of the disease and
you need to be tested today I spoke to a
woman who told me that her mother who
had been showing symptoms and was
severely ill for ten days had been
tested 2 times negative until she was
tested positive so until that moment she
was also not in the statistics so there
is the mess on the ground ground that
seems to be going on is of course has an
impact on the statistics this is one
thing the other thing is that there is
of course a deep sitting mistrust of
what authorities report what authorities
allow to report everybody in China knows
there is censorship and of course this
is why these citizen journalists go
there to get a glimpse of reality ok the
state is responding to what you
described this deep-seated mistrust um I
want to quote a state media here it says
anyone who tries to cover up the extent
of the outbreak will be nailed on the
pillar of shame for eternity is China
living up or attempting to live up
changing its ways in the direction of
transparency in regard to the
coronavirus
what China has done is that after in the
beginning denying that the virus could
spread from human to human
it admitted that it could spread from
human to human and it started publishing
figures and these figures are rising so
to some extent China is admitting that
something is happening but whether it's
living up to any standards of
transparency is something that's very
hard to say without independent
investigations and reporting and China
has not allowed journalists to report
freely although more freely than before
and it has not allowed or has limited
independent assessments by specialists
so no it is not of course living up to
transparency as we understand it and in
the process creating a real thirst for
information Matias Burling f-words in
Beijing thank you very much for that